[Music]  how was it how did it feel I had a great  time man I loved playing music and I  just loved everybody in that room and I  was just so happy to sing for the world  you know it's a blessing every day thank  you the songs are blessing too isn't it  you know it's a really special song and  I I know that that might sound like not  like a good thing to say coming from the  person that co-wrote it you know but you  know we had a special moment in that  room together me and Mark Ronson and  Anthony Marissa mondo and andrew Wyatt  you know it was like two guitars a bass  a piano a typewriter and us just you  know talking and singing back and forth  and more and having a conversation and  it's a conversation between a man and a  woman and I think that represents a lot  you know we all in this world we need to  keep talking and we need to keep talking  about the things that are important not  the shallow but the deep was  [Music]